Good morning.
I'm Maura Marx, the director of the Secretariat at Harvard.
Before we continue we have an announcement to make this morning.
This one is about interoperability which we have heard a lot about this one
It is about the potential of DPLA  to be a player in a
truly global information infrastructure.
First, thanks to [ Indiscernible Name ].
Now we ask Jill Cousins ,
director of Europeana foundation.
I make this announcement on behalf of Europeana and DPLA.
I feel very privileged to be hereat the launch of DPLA.
It is a wonderful addition
and with the energy that all of you have,
and you are putting into it, it will happen.
At Europeana  we have done some of the things that you are starting.
You are very welcome to use all of that as you help us
move forward. It will help those of us -- both of us.
I would like DPLA not to reinvent  the wheel but the car
to move forward. Gaining traction and speed.
Earning from our mistakes. And make something bigger and better.
For all of us to share. We already share a common goal.
To make the riches of libraries, museums, archives
and audiovisual collections available,
free of charge to everyone.In this mission,
we have set out principles to follow between the DPLA and Europeana.
The first is to make our systems and data interpretable.
The second, his two most -- promote open access through policies
and actions on content, data and metadata.
The third is different -- to develop collaboratively
where we can. Beginning with a droppable data model.
If you can't -- interoperable data model.
If you can say that, you are had.
I cannot tell you the pain and years already.
Based on the data and it is a beginning.
To share our source codes
and to cooperatively build our collections together.
To prove this is not just talk.
We are starting doing something very concrete.
Showcasing the can't -- content and links.
It is a virtual exhibition of the migration of Europeans to the Americas.
and Europeana will demonstrate the potential of the
combined collections by digitizing
and making freely available material about the journey
from the old world to the new.
[ APPLAUSE ].
This exhibition will include text,
images about the experiences as they are abandoning their
homes to seek new lives thousands of miles across a
treacherous ocean. Letters, photographs
and official records open unfamiliar views into the harsh world
and inhabited by Europeans in the activities of Russia to
the present fillets -- villages of Ireland.
Illustrating the culture shock
and immigrants of -- after a rifle.
Everyone in the United States,
including the Indians sent from immigrants
and everyone in Europe has some connection with migrated
All will be invited to stroll digitally through this rich exhibition.
Most importantly to interact
and participate as users add their own stories and memorabilia.
[ APPLAUSE ].
We are so excited to begin this work.
A word of thanks to Professor.
Robert for building all of the ties with the other
European partners.
Back to your regular scheduled programming I give you can
21 the presidenta lot of Peggy Rudd.
I have the privilege of moderating the panel of these
distinguished individuals.
Each of whom has been invited from their own
perspectiveto address the question of what is DPLA.
Particularly we asked them to do is to share some of
their patient of whatthe DPLA might be.
Also, to offer their perspectives on the promise ofthe DPLA.
The format is, each has been invited to speak to us for 5-7 minutes.
I will move things along to ensure it happens.
To allow sufficient,
of time for their engagement with you.
I also want to knowledge as was done previously.
We have an audience that goes beyond this room.
And eventual throw the country who are being a part of
this but in listening mode.
In the room you have the opportunity to actually engage
in the way you saw earlier today. We'll go in order
and they are seated in the order which they are listed in the program.
We'llbegin with Maureen Sullivan.
Who-- John Palfrey. Who is the chair of DPLA Thank you.
Before I do the official, what is DPLA.
I want to knowledge the incoming new president who has
joined is also. One that has yet to be mentioned. Tony,
welcome and thank you.What is DPLA?
It has been a complex indication of questions.
He honest answer is we are building it
and it is a virgin -- bridge we are walking over
and visual terms. By design,
we sought to build a together rather than say,
a particular version of what I speak-- might be.
I want to describe five aspects of DPLA .
We can work further on what the concrete aspects of each
of those will be. Let me hit them. They are on the screen.
These are the areas we know, after 18 months of our planning phase and moving forward,
we will have gotten work done
and we will aim for further work from there.
We talked about content in the middle of this list. That is clearly part of DPLA.
We will be digitizing materials
and we will be doing it with Europeana.
I hope we will work with the Internet archive
and lots of others to digitize content.
I don't think the idea is that it will be one big massive
digital library in one place but rather a collection of collections.
It is something we will have to figure out how to preserve overtime.
Even from the perspective of low hanging fruit.
If we were institutions that together spend millions of
dollars digitizing every year,
to do it in a common way based on common standards.
We are to ask people to use a common format
and to share to make sure a copy of itis shared with DPLA.
We could do a huge amount test thereby making the
existing collections and contents more interoperable and common formats.
It is much more than the digitize materials.
Starting from the top of the list is code.
Importantly, the DPLA is computer controlled we are developing.
We have made attempts to do as much as possible on open
space. It will be a set of code
and it will be like source code for libraries.
There are many ways in which we are working on this effort.
DPLA itself will be  repository of offensive code anyone
can take and reuse in different ways.
Imagine future would be DPLA  website to access the
contents but a bunch of code that a public library might take and repurpose for its own use.
They could curate collections and perhaps a library would take the code and repurpose it for their website
and bring some of the content that we have in our collection and curate it locally.
A second thing that is the same mix is the data. -- Metadata.
In the information there -- business it is one thing to
scan the data but it is another thing to refine it and make it usable.
It is something that I think we haven't structured right
yet in the world of libraries and information.
Information in the form of metadata has been too locked up
and I think we are going to make a real contribution by
having open access to metadata very broadly through this project.
We have heard earlier today that efforts to make link to open data
and to make information more broadly available in this
form.The DPLA  is and will be metadata in an open way.
There is a project called library class.
This is the part where I think it is most playful and exciting.
DPLA has the possibility that just be  a common platform
code but a series of services that libraries
and others could use to make this information richer and more available
and bring people in to allow social media [ Indiscernible- low volume ].
That might right on top of the common platform.
A favorite example of this, where is Emily core?
She coined the term, "scanabego".
Going to local historical societies
and saying bring out your scans.
Let's do this together.
There is material that has not yet put into this
wonderful cloud we are developing and metadata around it.
I can see this working with [ Indiscernible Name ].
I have an extremity data on the slide I will put the real
thing, community.
I think the DPLA is us. We are the DPLA.
It's an amazing  rich occasionally cranky, contentious community.
A community that I think has public spirit the behind it and will work together. As institutions and individuals.
Hopefully always with common respect and a goal in mind to build something no one institution could build on its own.
When we heard from the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian Library there is no one back into the
DPLA as well as we can.  If we structure this right,
we actually have good will and trust one another and work hard.
Petitions that have been made possible by Wikipedia, the Web itself,
we can do the same in the library world
and that is what DPLA is.
[ APPLAUSE ]
Now we have the opportunity to hear from transferring
three leads the Texas State Library and Archives commission
and on the steering committeefor the DPLA.
If you liked writing-- driving "scanabego" would be a tiring job for librarians.
I think it is especially important that we are here at
the national archives for this plenary session.
This is in fact national archives month.
We are celebrating all of the archives held at the
national state and local levels throughout our country.
We do have our own declaration of independence.
That is on display. In Austin Texas. It is digitized and available on the web.
I think so many of us have been focusing on content as well as we should.
We want to know what is this thing calledthe DPLA.
What is it going to look like we it also has two do with
the tools that John was talking about yesterday.
That Carl and I were hosting. Someone said,
they want to see someone walking down the sidewalk
and they have their cell phone. They have a question
and they say to themselves.I am going to DPLA it.
Just the way they say Google it.
That is what we want to see.
If we take as our guiding principles.
Something that Chairman Leach said earlier which I really
just loved. That is the infrastructure of ideas.
If we take as our guiding principle that all people in this country,
should have access to this infrastructure of ideas.
One of the issues we have to deal with in addition to all
of the things that Johnson. The metadata, content,
tools and services, community.
That just the community of those that are going to be
involvedin building the DPLA Those that are going to be
involved in sharing what is built.
We have to think about access.
I think many of us were present --
-- Even though I am a state librarian.
We do a lot of work as to state ivories all across the country.
With the infrastructure of more than 16,000 public library outlets in this country.
We have a built-in infrastructure.
We are very proud of that built-in infrastructure.
We think in terms of access for people who are -- whose
lives are going to be improved by having access to the DPLA.
We are going to be the digital literacy corps.
Those of us in public ivories.
Think about the work -- public libraries.
I think about the work in the media centers at the
Chicago public Library.
I think about the work Carla Hayden is doing here in Baltimore.
I think about the youth centers that have been going for
a decade with Dell foundation funding it at the public library they are.
Libraries, public ivories are going to be the institution that ensures that not only can people discover.
They can efficiently and effectively discover things in this wonderful thing
we are all going to build together.
They also are going to help people evaluate what it is they find.
They will ensure that they find is relevant to whatever their purposes.
And help them get the most out of the digital public library of America.
I think we are all committed to digital inclusion.
We understand that this is a major challenge are you a
challenge now. In our country.
Public libraries have risen to that challenge
and I think they will continue to you so.
I would submit that what we build is going to be grand and glorious.
Many of us have already built components that are going
to enrich the digital public library of America.
We are all committed to bringing this to fruition.
We must remember they are -- there are those in our
country that will need our special assistance for a whole variety of reasons.
To make sure they can use this tremendous resource that we are committing to today.
Thank you.
That that -- [ APPLAUSE ].
Next we have the opportunity to hear from Brewster Kahle.
Internet Archive.
You have a tie on. [ LAUGHING ].
I grew up in the paper world.
I believe we are in the transition of building a digital
America. This project is a key component to it.
I believe the archivist is correct. If it is not online, it does not exist.
All of the materials necessary to bring up the next generation and our own generation.
Our lockup in our physical paper libraries. And not accessible.
This is not good enough.
This project can be a major step towards fixing this.
There are two digital library projects that are now operating in the United States.
They are fairly large scale. There are many smaller ones.
There is a 10 million book collection offered as a
subscription service but there is a contractual litigation limitations.
There is a smaller collection of about 2 million books.
That is now available for free public access for the public domain.
And a free public lending library which we find
and in choosing approach towards moving -- an interesting
approach towards moving ahead. What do we want?
If we take this as a new starting point.
Where are we really trying to get to?
Let's make sure we have at the end of the day a lot of publishers. That are paid.
They sure if there are a lot of authors and booksellers.
Many many libraries that are not all responsible to central control.
There is a diversity of everyone of these among many to
many to many. A lot of authors many of which can get paid.
Last of all, let's be sure everyone can be a reader.
No matter what their language, disabilities, proclivities.
Everyone can be supported in this digital world.
Frankly it is the world that we benefited from,
growing up. Let's make sure the next generation has,
even though as you look around the room.
The number of laptops, it is a digital world now.
Let's go and adapt to it and support it and build it.
First of all, let's go and get a library that is as great as the Boston public Library.
Yell or Princeton library online accessible to all.
Materials that are public domain, out-of-print and in print.
Those libraries are about on the order of 10 million
volumes. We cannot stop there.
But let's be sure we do this
and I think we can quite effectively.
About 2 million books public domain 7 million out-of-print and 1 million in print.
I suggest three strategies for these different go categories. Public domain should stay free.
Out of print, can be digitized to be lent.
Digitally lent and that is in process.
And happening at scale.
There is also in print. It's by e-books and lend them.
They want us to be put to do this but we have billions of
dollars, collectively in the library systems to buy books. Let's go into what it is we are used to doing which is
acquiring things for our collections perfectly and lend them.
If we buy 100 copies there can be 100 copies circulating at once. Buying e-books and lend them.
Digitize the books that we cannot buy. And them
and give away the public domain.
I am happy to say that this is happening at scale.
There are now 1000 libraries that have digitize books
that are modern books. In copyright books. And lending them, digitally.
Also there -- they are sharing about 100,000 books.
You say, well, is that scale?
I would say that it's moving by having a large number of
libraries that we are moving forward with this approach with digitally lending
and solving one of the key problems which is how do we
get the collections that are not commercially viable online?
How do we support a wide number of vendors going forward? What can this project do?
I trains out of this project is to help libraries by new
e-books so they can lend them.
Two scanned the core collection of 10 million books
available to every citizen everywhere in the world are you since this has American in the title,
at least the United States.
Third, help a libraries get the complete digital collections.
It has been amazing to me. If you wanted a 10 million volume collection.
The size of that collection if it were on spinning,
searchable our drives is to computers about the size.
A 10 million books collection downloadable server will cost about $30,000.
That is within the budget of a lot of ivories.
I think they will take very different use of it.
There are different conceptions than having one centralized database.
Which may have been necessary in the mainframe era that
is is no longer necessary. What do we get?
Universal access to all knowledge. For inspiring generation.
We would be doing our part so that people all over the world can learn from.
How do we stand track? I always try to follow the monkey.
Is it being spent towards building these goals?
Or is it spent.
I would -- I am always looking to follow the money
and the bits. The resulting bits are they
and a lot of libraries are one place?
The thing I love is it is committee to put the bits
and in many places even if in copyright materials.
Because libraries can handle copyrighted materials on
their Cheryl's in new and different ways.
Together we can build -- build digital America.
As it is carved above the door of the Boston Library.
Free to all.
Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ].
Amanda French from  Center for History
and New Media is next.
[ Indiscernible - low volume ].
Go to her husband that the king will live.
Love alike. See the notes for clients don't hours, days,
months chart the rise of time.
John done -- Dunn. This is about loving and morning.
[ Indiscernible - low volume ].
Serenade us before, word.
We are familiar enough of the scene is when from you
and Juliet argue whether that is a large or night in jail.
-- Nightingale.
In the world of work the sun is rising is the beginning.
While for lovers the Suns raising is an on welcome ending.
Those of us who was cash flow folks,
three separate ideas suffer put that can grow.
They are now in the position of a voter tables up in
someone's warm winds at dawn.
The unruly sons of digital text is rising
and calling us to plotting work to the daily tally of bureaucracy.
When I for one would rather stuff down under the covers
with a book. Or with Bible of it ideals about books.
My love song for the ride.
As we have known it with praise for shovel to the fact
that the libraries papers cost me nothing.
It is perfectly possible that love can exist in a
commercial relationship area I am speaking of ideals.
I would praise a libraries infinite variety from Robert
Brunning tomorrow Roberts.
Thirdly I appreciate collaborated that will support me in
my moods of [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
As well as my moods of ruckus comedian.
All of these by the cold aspects of the soul of the
library. I could log. Libraries I have loved.
My love is not atomic.
This done -- [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
Loves mysteries and souls grow but yet the body is his book.
We need for a. -- We need proof of love.
Coffee tables have been compiled with cathedrals of
culture.Howard DPLA be embodied ?
I think DPLA must manifest itself as more than  a website.
There must also be in the largely hidden and quiet services as well.
Generous services to the public, developers,
existing libraries. These services must be technical and social
and might include the things we already heard about today.
Open data and metadata, APIs, preservation services in the form of its own repository.
Literacy and reference services. And continual attention to accessibility. And discoverability
and policy work at the highest level of national government.
A site that aggregates existing content without providing
such services would seem like a [ Indiscernible Name ]
in a lovely statue of no real humanity beyond what we project.
Although I fully agree of those who say it is not online it does not exist.
I think that is something that is only online.
Perhaps only half exists. A public building,
not just the data center or the warehouse.
I don't need a belly, but I want it was irrational desire.
I know it is not on the radar yetfor the DPLA.
I wanted to plant the seed of the idea today.
A monument to the ideal of having -- informed citizen.
A monument to a culturally intellectually and emotionally enriched citizen.
Within the city of monuments. We are in a monument today.
One important note about the obad enclosing.
Overture plan to reunite in the evening of the very same
day on which they part reluctantly in the morning.
Are allowed to figure in the obad.
It is not just for lovers who anticipate they'll painful
and perhaps permanent separation.
I am confident that hours is one such obad.
Our own work day will end with a gleeful fun if you with
the soul and body of a library.
[ APPLAUSE ]
There have been many memorable phrases throughout this.
The last one, the gleeful rendezvous with the soul
and body of a library is one to remember.
We have the privilege at the start of this session of
hearing American Library Association six describe the
commitment of European genre to the public library.
We have the opportunity to hear her perspectives on the
vision and the promiseof DPLA.
They are entirely selfish.
And I am not Californian tree if I cannot do anything.
Without sites.
-- Slides.
It is really [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
We can get access to your stuff. [ APPLAUSE ].
I am prepared to give access to your stuff we hold you
back. There is a lot more sites. Also,
I think you can improve on Europeana.
It is about the data, open source and licensing.
Licensing is my latest mantra.
It is about being interoperable with each other.
Together we can give each other on both sides of the
Atlantic more and give it to them faster.
This is Europeana.
This year we launched a strategic plan.
This plan is for four years.
It has four major strands.
The reason for pushing this on you.
It helps a-- we frame what I want out of DPLA.
Europeana is about aggregating.
It is about building the open trusted source to European
cultural [ Indiscernible Name ].
It is about facilitating and supporting cultural Heller kit -- heritage.
Transfer to advocacy.
It is about making the heritage available to users
wherever they are and wherever they want it.
Lastly it is about engaging that user in ways to
participate with their cultural heritage.
I have already heard today in this morning and yesterday.
It is exactly the same mission you are trying to accomplish.
When I look at these numbers I am slightly -- I was proud actually.
What from 2 million in three years to 20 million.
I do the numbers you are talking about
and I will have some of that. We are doing okay.
We started very much as you have started.
And we are moving on.
The thing I am especially interested in is APIs.
To distribute the contents back into the places where the user will use it.
I don't think I would expect them to come to DPLA.
You should expect them to come to the sites.
We need to put stuff through APIs. So the curators
or a school sites can actually make it work for the kids.
We are not going to be able to do that.
Which would have the capability unless we put it with people who can make that kind of thing work.
It is about being able to take back what already belongs
to America through these APIs.
This is a search on American, United States.
So just three languages.
It brings the kind of content that relates to the USA on
that. It is mapped and it is Christmas cards.
It is a lot of archived materials especially off of the second world war.
Also things like videos of people turning out [
Indiscernible Name ].  All of that belongs to you
and you should have it back in the DPLA.
Facilitate.
The reason I am interested in this has to do with open
data. Open licensing. We heard some of that already.
We are doing a lot of work on labeling the content so
that you know it is in the public domain.
We issued a charter that says what was in the public
domain in other forms should stay in the public domain in digital form to
and I need your help to make sure that goes on.
That we label it with the public domain which is being
developed with the [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
We really make sure that we don't lose this for the
future. This was a search on Washington.
The public domain is only 36 related to Washington.
This one is from the national archive in the Netherlands.
It is a song about George Washington.
I think when he went to [ Indiscernible Name ].
That's where about it. Lastly,
it is not -- it is about being able to engage.
You may have heard me [ Indiscernible Name ] about
projects where  involved in.
It is called transcendent 1918.
Is based on an idea that came out of the University.
With it, we go around museums and libraries
and ask people to bring you the memorabilia.
They bring in all sorts of things.
Photos with bullet holes through them that they got back
from their uncle who was killed. We get diaries,
diaries kept I children during those period.
They are digitized the stories and online.
We have done that in Germany
and we are going around the rest of Europe.
I would really like to be able to extend that.
If you would like to take the next exhibition we do after
my migration. And hit 2014.
And look at the stories beyond the world wars.
This pulls in all of the items that we hold in our
institutions into the video.
It is a story about a prisoner of war
and a captain in a British army who together put out a
fire. I need -- [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
In this  video you can start to: things from YouTube
and the maps of the trenches
and all of those things that you read through the videos.
The aim is to make it very interesting.
Why is DPLA important?
We are the generation that's can give access to the past.
We were brought up on books, manuscripts, pictures.
We visited a museum, the libraries, archives and galleries.
We know what is fair and how important it is.
We -- with your kids, if we don't digitize it and put it online.
For me that is the reason why DPLA  is a fantastic idea.
Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ].
The person writing is Carl Malamud with  people resource.org.
I'm from California
and I don't believe in color for you but I do want a soapbox.
I want to thank Dave for allowing us to occupy [
Indiscernible Name ] today.  Especially to pop chart
and who has been our profit to the justice promised land
of the republic of letters.
Plus they force us to-- Professor. far I have spent.
I keep seeing images of reservoirs and are just.
When I think of the DPLA I think of the Hoover dam
and Golden gate Bridge. If you look at the museums
and our  archives and research institutions,
there is a tremendous reservoir of knowledge locked up.
It is tempting to think our world of knowledge born digital.
We are flooded with information that we need what Clay
Johnson calls information diet. We don't need more data.
Our Internet is only flooded with some kinds of information right now.
Some of the most important tools of knowledge are not available to all.
Or available only to those with gold red cards
or positions of privilege in our league institutions.
Knowledge in the world wants to the 1%.
I can give you two examples
and I think you can think of them. The first is law and government.
The law, court opinions or statutes or regulations.
Public safety codes. The operating system of our society
and the rules that make democracy work.
It is the code that makes America such a special place.
The private houses have enclosed this was public domain and.
Access to justice has become all about access to money.
We give you whatever example.
If you are creative. A writer or film maker or an artist. A scholar.
You draw on imagery of accumulated over thousands of years.
Imagery you use to create new works of art and scholarship.
Creative workers the stand on the shoulders of giants. If we are to reach new heights.
As any Hollywood filmmaker will tell you much of that
imagery is locked up in for project -- profit places. They have built walls and gates around them.
Even our museums.
Even our national step only in -- Smithsonian situation.
Allowing images to use -- the used only by those who stop by a cash register first.
There is a tremendous reservoir of this untapped knowledge in America.
Knowledge is our countries host important renewable natural resource.
It is a common pool that should be available to all.
We already have many beautiful museums. We have autobus libraries. Unique research institutions.
What if the DPLA, instead of creating another institution created a common
reservoir that we could help campaign two.
What if the trust put everything they have into a common pool.
A pool being turned could draw upon to create an even
more impressive trust? What if the Internet archive
and Library of Congress and public libraries and individuals
and local historical societies could all draw on those
deep wells and all contribute to the common pool?
Is tempting for anyone institution to say, I have the answer.
What if we shift the debate so it becomes,
we all have the answer, here's my contributions.
To see what you can do with it. Surprise me.
I have one more than the four. Then I will stop beating this metaphorical horse.
Metaphor is a bridge.
The specific bridge is the Washington Bridge.
It connects the Washington Capitol with the rest of the country.
When it comes to untapped resources,
Washington is the deepest well.
A vast storehouse locked inside the Beltway.
But the national kosher will institution.
The Library of Congress, national Library of medicine.
The Smithsonian.
The national technical information service.
The Government printing office. The national archives.
The list goes on.
What we have clinched a few shining examples of that potential.
The American memory potential of the Library of Congress.
Pioneering national -- for the most part those resources
they hidden areas it is our opportunity to build a bridge to Washington.
That means we need to get much for serious about public
works projects for knowledge.
We need to start on national digitization initiative that
is more than pilots and prototypes.
We need a decade of long commitment to scanning.
Or federal government to understand it is time to deploy
the Internet Corps of Engineers. To scan it scale
and become much more serious contributor to that reservoir of knowledge.
To be at the center of that public part that makes access
to knowledge a right for all Americans not a privilege
for the 1%. If a self-appointed library
and in an abandoned church like first retail can publish 3 million posts,
how can the federal government not to more?
If Google can scan 10 million books to feed a search engine,
why can't the federal government do the same to transform
our nation's educational system?
If Westlaw can scan the it opinions of courts
and statutes of legislatures to maximize shareholder value,
why can't the judicial conference of the United States
and/or nation's law schools work together to maximize
Democratic values. If we can put a man on the moon ,
why can't we launched the Library of Congress into cyberspace?
If we spend billions of dollars to buy access to politicians,
why can't we spend billions of dollars to buy access to
knowledge and justice to promote the useful arts,
car must -- car buyers -- commerce area these are the
kinds of bridges and reservoirs we can build.
The kinds of public projects that can become the foundation of the digital public libraries of America.
It is the opportunity we can replace.
That only -- but only if we work together. Thank you.
[ APPLAUSE ] [ CHEERS ]
As a moderator, I will exercise the privilege of moving to audience
participation on this question.
Rather than invite you to comment on what you heard from the six.
Instead, reflect for a few moments on the wealth of information and ideas shared today.
I would like you to consider what is the potential ofthe
DPLA ? In the communities to which you are parts?
I would invite you to share that with all of us here this
morning. What is the potential you see?
One other thing, state your name and be brief.
Rutgers University. [ Indiscernible Name ].
As a faculty of aIvory school.
I hope DPLA will have  fellowship's
or scholarships to help the upcoming librarians learn all of the skills they need
or if we already launched courses in digital libraries,
metadata, data federation. We need more
and we need to be on the front line.
Thank you.
I am aware of the richness among the six but there is
richness in the audience.
[ Indiscernible - low volume ].
I a passionate supporter of this project.
The presentations this point however have exposed an
issue that hadn't occurred to me before.
I would like to make a suggestion.
The proposition that if it doesn't exist online, it does not exist.
This seems, if true, unfortunate.
There are aspects of our cultural heritage that can never
be fully appreciated in a digital format.
Graphic art. It can be suggested.
But never indicated. Online. Find musical performances.
Certain historical events.
I appreciate -- an appreciation of the Holocaust cannot
be fully cleaned from digital materials.
At a minimum it has to be the texture.
If the Digital the library succeeded only. -- Fully.
As a hazard I had not previously recognized that it would
suppress our appreciation of some other aspects of our
cultural heritage is -- heritage is..
There is an unavoidable competition.
We would observe
and regret the extent to which our children was
appreciation for some things we did enjoy.
There is an alternative path which one could build into the project from the beginning.
Techniques, not just for digitizing currently analog materials for
providing access to indices were sensitized appreciation of this.
It can be as simple as a guidance for where musical
performances are currently located
or something more [ Indiscernible Name ]. Fundamental.
You were addressing the second question I was going to post if there was time.
What would you suggest are important things to consider as this work moves forward?
Critical success factors. I appreciate that.
Other perspectives on the process of DPLA?
14 Gomez. Los Angeles public library.
I see potential for many of the kids that are served by
Los Angeles public Library for example.
To get excited about knowledge. If a nation in mourning.
Pulling pieces together that are important to them in their own communities.
Thank you.
Zachary Davis from can -- can cannon foundation.
How do we make sure public libraries continue to be a
space for learning and education.
How can we transform the use of these libraries so the
building and become potential temples to knowledge?
In a place of -- that is the idea.
What do we do with the places so they are still usable?
I will take a crack at that.
I think that Susan eluded to this.
In her presentation earlier this morning.
I think what we're seeing is public libraries they in
fact have to evolve. Many of them are already doing that.
I think one of the exciting features that I envisioned
for the digital public library of America is that it will
incorporate user created content.
All of that is being fed in,
if you will laboratories in public libraries across the
country. I was talking earlier about digital inclusion.
I think we have to realize that when you look at a survey
that just came out. From connected nation.
46% of going come families with children don't have
computers or Internet access.
I think they deserve access to the digital public library
of America. I agree with Terry.
If a child is growing up in some of the major cities in this country.
There isn't always a digital placement for a firsthand experience.
Of a cultural event.
If you are a child growing up in [ Indiscernible Name ] Texas.
I promise you the only cultural heritage organization
or institution within 100 miles is the public library.
I think public libraries are going to change.
I think of it more,
not a library without walls but beyond walls.
I think everybody very in this country has experiences that they can share.
About all the ways that their libraries are being used in
ways that, whether at Rutgers or University of Texas or Denver.
Whatever library or school or high school you could never have envisioned the use of
the five very in that way.
I see public libraries is being integral to the
developmentof DPLA because I think that is where user
created content is going to surface. And it's surfacing.
I also think that that is the role that libraries are
going to bloody to create an environment in which people can access digital content,
when there is no access anywhere else.
I know I have one on this slide.
Is anyone on that site leasing -- I am from Boston Massachusetts.
Free for all these words that I pass every day.
On the face of the bus and public library.
We appreciate your comments because I signaled his fellow
that I wanted to speak as you were mentioning bandwidth.
I think is a critical issue especially in oral areas. -- Rural areas.
A technical aspects of working on digital public
libraries takes into account that you will have a lot of
data images and very heavy use of the bandwidth.
How are we going to build the bandwidth access through public libraries.
I think that was one reason why we were so glad to see [
Indiscernible Name ] with the Gates foundation.
They have worked with particularly Ivory semi-state but across the country.
To upgrade bandwidth in public libraries.
And to sustain that over a period of time.
I think that is one of the critical issues that feeds
into digital inclusion. If your library has 1. 5 Mb connection,
and you have kids pouring into your library after 3:00 in the afternoon. Trust me.
It is not going to be long before everyone is saying,
why is it so slow? Why can't I do this that or the other?
That is a key component of what we are talking about with
DPLA Stephen Kirkpatrick from [ Indiscernible Name ].
We serve many of those underserved first generation to college students.
Community means a great deal to us there.
I think of community in two respects.
Imagine an Ecuadorian American mother who is a part-time
student majoring in finance.
She belongs to a lot of communities.
We want the content of course that serves all of those communities.
I would also be interested in making sure that the coding
that goes into this recognizes that not just her but all
of us have multiple communities we belong to.
I would hope whatever exists would allow her to shift
from her parents in the interest.
And get the advantage of social searching.
Then suddenly switch to the finance major
and also have the benefit of the social aspect of searching.
With other finance measures. Etc.
Does anyone on the panel want to reflect on this?
We all agree.
.Our old -- Jon Arnold, software engineer.
I have watched this developed.
I want to point out two things of interest.
First of all,
one of the ideas in the 1991 White House conference on
White House services which is another reference point.
So are some groups talked about wasn't just scanning but
the ability that maybe having a central point where
people could send their homes movies and 8 mm
and not have to pay through the nose to get some of those
activities. Not only in our families
and families across the country but in the public ivories
have films donated operates from the turn of the century.
Or from World War II. The other thing,
getting back to the question about the potentialof DPLA.
I see DPLA has a huge potential for bring up resources
right now  used at the local libraries so the local
library can send its scarce resources on customizing a
property available set of content to exactly what the community needs.
But the local trustees are deciding to do.
Even better than not having a great pool of lots of content to choose from.
The library can customize it for the community.
Is one feels they are not a good fit for the community.
The library can provide an audience of one by letting the person customized library for themselves.
Thank you. That was great.
[ Indiscernible Name ]. Recent library  science graduate. From New York.
My question is not really related to the professionals.
But more to, how does the private citizen.
The everyday person.
Get involved in this project from its beginning stages.
I am not asking about the scanning part of it. But, getting involved somehow.
Writing letters to Washington. Or for treating funds?
-- Contributing funds?
I'm thrilled to have this tested.
We spend our last session on this topic. The answer is, lots of ways.
Her imagination is probably the will limit year.
I love the lobbying point and second to last.
There is a big globalization question here.
It goes to many of the concerns that have been expressed about the affect of this project on public libraries.
The notion is, people say because you
have a DPLA rid your for donate a local library.
Obviously everyone in the room things that is a crazy statement.
We know there are crazy people in politics.
That is an unfortunate reality.
A test of the word out about what this is
and it is a complex or supplement to the -- complement or supplement.
To do that anyway that I think in the end abrogates more
resources to this knowledge pool
and the system we are talking about.
I don't think there is any -- I would be so sorry if this
project led to the closure of one library.
I think to the point of other comments that have been brought through.
This is absolutely not about shutting libraries.
That is happening anyway and it is not our fault.
It is a problem in the world.
Hopefully these spaces will be much richer and used for more things. Freeing up librarians time.
To giving money.
I think we should find a way to have a fund we all could
give private resources to. We have not done that.
We should.
More specifically to the broad question how you can get
involved in setting up this project? The goodness
and badness of having questions about what that itis of
DPLA.  On the other hand we are struggling with and working through it.
The other hand they want our help
and there is opportunity.
There are six work streamsset up for the DPLA.  Go to dp.
la or Google us. Today is in parts,
meant as an invitation to everyone and everyone watching.
To come join those work streams.
To participate in the shaping of what this should be. A range from governance to legal issues, to technical
and audience participation.
There are going to be series of meetings over 18 months.
That will be open to anyone who wants to participate.
We will post when they happen.
You can purchase at a in virtual ways or come to the meetings.
They will be shared -- chaired
and a way to manage broad participation.
It will take up a series of issues we know we have to deal with.
One talk about what we are actually building and we have raised key issues in that area.
Those who have or technical abilities will be hugely helpful.
We talk about how we take the beta sprints
and built upon them into something common.
Also taking the open code andnot to deal with the DPLA.
On the technical aspects.
We also need people who will imagine the use cases.
How will these be used and which we people think we there is a huge range of
opportunities across these different projects.
Over the 18 months we have -- we come back together.
If we have three or people in the room, that would be great.
If we have 10 times that of the want to be in here,
that is going to be a big piece of the success.
To all library students and everyone here, come join us.
There is more than enough work to do.
There is scanning and riding in the back of the bus would be fun.
[ LAUGHING ].
[ Indiscernible Name ].
Early childhood [ Indiscernible Name ].
I am honored to be a former person. Children's librarian.
I've always believed children who go to the library
become parents who go to the library.
What you have in the collection for children?
I am talking about the emerging reader as well.
I want to know, what is the by in for a parent to use the digital public library of America.
I know or see the reasons for academic.
It is very academic focus. I see it is great for history.
When I am talking about is the 0-8.
What is it about Amanda French  I as -- Digital Public
Library of America  will say this why I want to use it.
Who want to be clear ofthe intent of DPLA.
This is like the last one.
A crucial thing we worked out conceptually.
I think the answer is,what the library is going to do
with DPLA. How is going to mediate that ways
or make sense for 0-8 euros.
That is one piece of the project. Creating the structure.
The common pool. That people can code upon.
And use it in ways that are richer
and more freely available.
We have to figure out if someone comes to a common
website, how we make it something available.
You have heard from thing she would have had trouble accessing before.
There are publishers in the world who are struggling with
this question. There are things that are digital and right now in print
and in copyright that lever use are having a hard time --
libraries are having a hard time getting to the 0 to 8.
We need to be a force broadly for helping that to happen.
Whether in DPLA or advocacy
or working with publishers on different bottles.
As a parent of young children, they be nothing.
There may be some degree to which we are still binding
books are checking them out of the library and reading the book.
Maybe how we want to do it in our household.
In the range of possibilities is enormous.
It is enormous especially because the platform right in
the community parts rightto what DPLA is.
I also think it is not a replacement for anything
and we should not see it that way.
It cuts to the lower age range that you're asking about.
The University of Texas at Arlington did a study about
one year ago looking at students in fourth grade and seventh grade.
Looking at what is it that is going to fully engage
students in the study of our state's history?
What is going to yield higher grades on standardized tests?
One thing they found is students performed better if they
had a greater extent of interaction with documents.
Real documents. If they had first-person experiences.
What we have tried to do at the Texas State Library
and many state ivories around the country have been
funding projects of their own institutions as well as
across their individual states.
That is bringing history to the classrooms so that
students can experience.
Rather than simply talking about our civilian conservation Corps Truong's of Texas.
Parks -- drawings of Texas or parks.
Any of the wealth of documents that we have.
We can digitize those and make them available.
So that in the enhances the experience of students.
As a study our state history.
Of course that is true for the study of United States
history's as well. That is used in classrooms.
That we in this level, I think.
Karo has one last comment.
Two examples. The Encyclopedia of life.
Pictures of bugs and lions and tigers and bears.
Amazingfolks on collections at the Library of Congress.
If we're successful to address Professor.
Fisher's point.
For being able to identify alliance entire Sim mayors --
the lions and tigers and bears.
I want to visit the Smithsonian when I go to the local zoo.
[ Indiscernible - low volume ].
I have a number of studies about libraries
and museums and archives doing digitize patients.
-- Digitization. [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
The phrase, if it doesn't exist online,
it does not exist  is a crash faith but it might be
useful -- if they can't -- [ Indiscernible - low volume ].
Let me) to words of thanks.
The first is on behalf of the panel to all of you
especially those who made comments
or responded to the questions I pose.
It was a meaningful experience
and engagement in this process.
You could also see from that, it is stimulating thinking
and helps advance the development of the DPLA.
I want all of you in the audience to join me in thanking the six panelists for their presentation.
[ APPLAUSE ].